saying bless you after sneezing is a
waste of time oh I don't agree with that
is a waste of time strongly disagree or
just disagree uh saying bless you
is now that you say
it like I wouldn't like it is actually
just a waste of time yeah but then you
could say that about manners do you know
what I mean why say Get It Anyway
manners is has a yeah but like if some
if I was if I was in a room and I
sneezed and you didn't see bless you I
I never say I I never say bless you do
you know I like I don't know what it is
about bless maybe it's a bit weird to
say bless you need actually say bless
cuz like think about how weird that is
like it's very religious it bless you
bless you bless you I think it comes
from the plague though you used to say
like God bless you you're going to die I
knew that I didn't know that no I didn't
know that no